there is one job no CEO should delegate
that job is interviewing Larry BCD who
turned around allied signal said that
the most important role of any manager
was interviewing jack welch spent over
fifty percent of his time hiring because
getting the best athletes in your team
is the thing that will lead your company
to success and yet we are so bad at
interviewing we've all been in those
interviews where the person across the
table looks like a complete Muppet they
lunge like Cougars at biases at
conclusions and yet we could by
implementing a structured
well-thought-out interview process
become great interviewers the best
athletes don't just turn up on the day
and race they spend months months
preparing and training Usain Bolt didn't
end up like that by just turning up on
the day so Scott's going to tell us why
interviewing is important Lauren is
going to tell us the biases that affect
our judgement and Hogg hair is going to
tell us how we can become better
interviewers so interviewing well is
important because it allows you to
select and attract the best candidates
pure and simple you interview well you
will be able to better select and
attract the best candidates so just by
show of hands who here actually
interviewed in their job before the
business school before you came to GSB
ok me too
now keep your hands up if as part of
that process at your old company
you were given rigorous training on what
to look for or how to select the right
candidates okay so we have two hands so
even though companies and people like
jack balls recognize it interviewing is
really important there's not a lot of
train that goes on in fact often times
people report in surveys that
interviewing is an area that they feel
really uncomfortable in and the bad news
is for all of us that are leaving the GS
being
to kind of middle management roles if we
go there will be this discomfort isn't
going away it's going to get even worse
as our job requires us to interview more
frequently now so you know that it's
easy it's important to select the right
candidate but attracting the right
candidates actually really important
because if you're like me you've
probably been in an interview where you
face really silly surface questions that
made you think gosh this guy was
interviewing me isn't that bright and
maybe you even felt like this this
little comic we're going to see myself
in five years another dumb question
prison so these questions are silly but
a lot of these a lot of times these
questions get asked and so just to
demonstrate how bad some interview
processes can go we'd like to
demonstrate a quick interview of an
interview process that's all - all too
often actually happens so Andre will be
playing the candidate at Dropbox and
I'll be playing the interviewer and so
who do we have wait
Andre hey I'm really great at reading
people so I don't need to read his
resume hi hi hi hello hey uh why don't
you uh why don't you tell me a little
bit about yourself and see success here
you you went to the GSB I went to the
GSB last 2003 great that's awesome
um so maybe the first question how's
your golf game
oh it's actually I mean it's it's it's
really come on I mean I skipped a lot of
classes to go on the course so hot great
yeah I'm yeah I like Dropbox but hey you
know when I was GSP that was that was an
amazing place man I miss it
yeah I've been asking the other folks
about modeling skills that's important
here but based on your background you at
the GSB and you can buy model pretty
well right I mean I haven't done them
actually yeah I'm probably pretty good
yet
yeah super well you know I got some more
work to do so I think you're a great fit
I'd love to hire you
great great oh hey welcome aboard Andre
so how does everyone think Scott did
that was pretty terrible right Scott
you're fired so why are we such bad
interviewers given the social nature of
interviews there's often significant
room for interpretation but it is not
just intentional favoritism or
stereotyping it is instead more often
one of the many unconscious cognitive
biases that can influence our ability to
judge talent and to hire effectively so
for instance when Scott said you
graduated from the GSB nice me too how's
your golf game this is an example of
similar to me bias in which we develop
an affinity for a candidate because he
or she shares personal characteristics
with us so instead of focusing on the
qualifications for the job at hand
we instead focus on shared background or
shared schooling or the fact that we
root for the same sports team and
similar any bias can also go
hand-in-hand with first impression Eric
as we heard from the first get first
impressions matter so what happens here
is our initial snap judgments in an
interview can set the tone and color the
rest of the interview time so no matter
what Andre said in the next 29 minutes
those first few instances can affect how
Scott reads whatever he says they're
after and these two biases can go hand
in hand with confirmation bias so
confirmation bias can occur when we seek
information that reconfirms
our pre-existing notions about an
individual and this can often lead to
inconsistency
and questioning when we treat different
candidates differently and ask them
different questions so we see this very
clearly when Scot said I usually ask
candidates about their modeling
abilities but given your background
I think that's unnecessary so Andre gets
a pass whereas all those other
candidates get hammered on question
after question after question on
analysis and modeling this is unfair yet
despite all of these biases we don't
realize our judgment is so bad why is
this yet another bias overconfidence
bias overconfidence bias occurs because
we all think that we have better than
average judgment and better than average
intuition that we're better than average
interviewers so therefore we don't even
question what we think when we make
judgments about a candidate this we saw
again in Scotts overconfidence when
before entering interview room he said
well I'm really really reading people so
I don't need to read this resume however
these biases really matter a couple of
small examples one it has been estimated
that over 30 percent of the game and
female orchestra members over a 20-year
period has been attributed to the use of
blind auditions in which candidates play
behind a curtain and even further some
research suggests that over 35% of
hiring choice variation can be explained
by a candidate's obesity so we can see
that these biases really matter so now
I'm going to turn it over to Jorge to
explain how we can become better
interviewers and how we can use an
interview process to overcome these
unconscious biases
so how does anybody become a better
interviewer as with all forms of
strategic communication he has our lives
in preparation I'm going to share with
you today three steps which anybody can
use to outline a process that is far
more efficient than a lot of the than
what we've been talking about here today
and actually selecting the right people
for the job the first step involves
thinking carefully about personally
you're going to hire about their job
profile job profile think about it as a
picture
the ideal portrait of what this
candidate is going to look there it must
look like to fulfill the needs of the
position and is this picture against
which you can then compare every one of
your candidates and ensure that you have
the best fit possible this portrait
should be built around both background
factors and personal factors both of
these are intricately linked to the next
steps of the process so I will discuss
them more detail in just a second the
second step is to select four resumes
that meet these requirements
now the resume selection selection stage
is the gate to the process and this is
where you want to really focus on not
letting commonalities or your gut
feeling get in the way to allow them
through the door you have to focus on
the education and the experience
requirements that are required of a
person to get to get this shot if you
need a rocket scientist this is an
extreme example but you of course need
somebody probably with a degree in fluid
mechanics mechanical engineering and a
PhD for example now once you make your
selection you go on to the last step
before the interview which is to devise
a personalized interview plan I call it
personalized because you need to focus
here on the personal factors of the
prayer of the candidate
these include intellectual ability has
to do with creative power creative
prowess analytical abilities or decision
making process you have to include
personality how dominant is this person
are they extroverted are they patient
and detail-oriented these are important
things to think about
finally motivation is incredibly
important
this might seem like common sense to you
guys and you don't need to be a fan of
the show Silicon Valley to understand
the differences between hiring a CEO and
the coder but you'd be surprised to see
how many people don't really think
carefully about this before engaging
candidates and interviews now it's very
important that you actually are focusing
on the position throughout this whole
process and not your personal
preferences or ideas now we're at the
interview it's very easy once you get to
the interview 2 and you have a resume in
front of you to let that sort of take
control and be your agenda do not let
that happen you need to come into this
interview with a set of topics that
you're going to use as your agenda and
these topics the details are not really
that important doesn't matter what the
topic is what you want to use this topic
for us to open up the conversation these
topic openers will then give you
information about the candidate the
specifics about where they worked who
they work with what specific project
they worked on or where they were
educated and here that's where you
launch the good questions this is what
the real interview is about you want to
focus on getting and delving deep into
the person that into this person and
then their personal factors through
probing questions either self appraisal
or situation waste as an example you can
ask the questions such as tell me about
a time when you had to make a decision
in the difficult situation for there was
no for which there was no policy now
these kinds of questions shed light into
their analytical or their intellectual
ability and their personality and to
avoid people falling back on pre-canned
answers you have to delve deeper into
those questions how do the people around
you react how did you overcome those
that were against whatever decision you
made and from this you can make your own
conclusions and you're going to repeat
the process over and over again until
you have all the information you need to
ensure that you have a fit of the
candidate to the portrait speaking of
conclusions I will give it over to Andre
now
there is nothing more important than
getting the rock stars on the rocketship
that you want your company to be the
best athletes in your team interviewing
is the way to get those people into the
fold and yet so often we've added it
we've added it because as you've heard
we don't practice we don't lift the
weights before the race Eli proteins
practice on the track so we'd like to
leave you with one message do the
practice do the training and bring those
those star athletes into your team thank
you